ya hablamos de lo grandioso que es el
carbono para la vida
hablamos de que la vida como la
conocemos está basada en el carbono y
todo eso es posible gracias a que el
carbono puede unirse con otros carbonos
y otros elementos como el oxígeno
hidrógeno entre otros incluso hay un
montón de moléculas conocidas como
moléculas orgánicas que son moléculas
que involucran al carbono y bueno en el
vídeo anterior dijimos que la capacidad
en la santé del carbono se debe a su
estructura electrónica verán el carbono
neutro tiene 6 protones y 6 electrones 2
de ellos se encuentran en la capa
electrónica interna o primera capa
electrónica y los otros cuatro se
encuentran en la capa externa son los
electrones que reaccionarán se les
conoce como electrones de valencia
entonces estos electrones de valencia
pueden formar cuatro enlaces covalentes
por ejemplo si se forma un enlace con
cuatro hidrógenos
cada hidrógeno contribuye con un
electrón para completar el par de
electrones y formar un enlace covalente
así los hidrógenos pueden sentir que su
capa externa está completa
los hidrógenos quieren tener dos
electrones para llenar su capa
electrónica y así parecerse al helio
mientras que el carbono quiere tener
ocho electrones para hacer como el neón
porque el neón tiene dos electrones en
la capa interna y ocho en su capa
externa pero si se acuerdan de la regla
del octeto los átomos quieren tener o al
menos pretender que tienen ocho
electrones en su capa externa para ser
estables y miren aquí el carbono está
compartiendo electrones contribuye con
cuatro y los hidrógenos contribuyen con
los otros cuatro así se forma el metal
ahora algunos de ustedes quizás se
pregunten ok yo sé que existen otros
elementos que tienden a formar cuatro
enlaces covalentes porque tienen cuatro
drones de valencia bueno en particular
hay uno en la tabla periódica que es muy
cercano al carbono se encuentra justo
aquí este es el silicio el silicio
neutro tiene 14 protones y 14 electrones
voy a dibujar aquí tenemos el silicio y
vamos a enfocarnos en los electrones el
silicio tiene 2 electrones en la primera
capa electrónica la capa interna y se
están moviendo alrededor después tenemos
8 electrones en la segunda capa
electrónica 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 y se están
moviendo pero como en total deben ser 14
y ya dibujamos 10 nos faltan 4
electrones esos están en la capa externa
aquí tenemos 12
34 estos cuatro son los que van a
reaccionar son nuestros electrones de
valencia así que el silicio tiene cuatro
electrones de valencia 1 2 3 4 4
electrones de valencia como el carbono y
miren aunque tiene más electrones que el
carbono solo esos 4 electrones
reaccionarán y podrán formar cuatro
enlaces covalentes y quizás se pregunte
podrá existir vida basada en el silicio
al igual que la vida basada en el
carbono bueno no son los primeros en
cuestionarse eso muchos autores de
ciencia ficción han propuesto lo mismo
por ejemplo aquí tenemos una imagen del
episodio el [ __ ] en la oscuridad de la
serie original de star trek que salió en
1967 donde kirk encuentra a esta
criatura una forma de vida basada en el
silicio que se hacía llamar corta así
que existen muchas personas que creen
que es posible que haya
vida basada en el silicio pero con la
química esa creencia se rompe un poco
les explicaré una de las mejores
cualidades del carbono es que puede
formar enlaces con otros carbonos y se
pueden formar muchos tipos de
hidrocarburos y estructuras carbono
carbono de cadenas muy largas todo eso
se puede hacer con el carbono pero
resulta que los enlaces que forman el
silicio no son tan largos
además el silicio no forma cadenas tan
largas incluso si analizamos la molécula
más simple que en el caso de carbono es
el metano en el caso del silicio es el
sila no pero no es tan fácil que se
forme y además tiene otras
características así que esto tampoco es
tan bueno como el metano y si pensamos
en algo como dióxido de carbono que se
compone de un carbono unido con dos
dobles enlaces a dos oxígenos aquí
tenemos el carbono unido con un doble
enlace
un oxígeno por aquí y por acá tenemos
otro doble enlace con otro oxígeno
entonces en la vida cotidiana hablamos
del dióxido de carbono como un gas por
ejemplo las plantas lo usan en su
fotosíntesis para poder crecer y
nosotros exhalamos dióxido de carbono
que es muy importante para la vida pero
qué pasa con el dióxido de silicio bueno
el dióxido de silicio es una molécula
muy común pero no existe en estado
gaseoso a las temperaturas en las que
normalmente se desarrolla la vida en
realidad la mayor parte del dióxido de
silicio se encuentra en los cuarzos en
la tierra cuarzo así que al analizar las
formas en las que se encuentra el
silicio podemos ver que no es tan bueno
como el carbón o simplemente el silicio
unido al oxígeno se encuentra en estado
sólido a las temperaturas en las que
normalmente se desarrolla la vida pero
estos son enlaces
muy fuertes más fuertes que los enlaces
que se forman entre el carbono y el
oxígeno estos enlaces son tan fuertes
que sería muy difícil manipular las
reacciones químicas que ocurren dentro
de los organismos así que es muy
divertido pensar en las teorías sobre
todo esto y yo sería la última persona
en establecer algo yo creo que el
universo continuará sorprendiéndonos con
cosas que en este momento ni siquiera
imaginamos pero por ahora basándonos en
la química y la vida como la conocemos
aunque el silicio tiene 4 electrones de
valencia y puede formar cuatro enlaces
covalentes no es tan bueno como el
carbono para realizar los procesos que
son necesarios para la vida